[Music]
Robert Spencer here for jihad watch a
program of the David Horowitz Freedom
Center and for the Center for Security
Policy the Orlando weeklies Xander
Peters frames a story this way Orange
County middle school teacher has an
incredibly racist Twitter account
according to Peters this teacher
retweeted an anti-muslim post by what he
called identify Europa that his identity
Europa a white supremacist group that
aims to create a white ethno state the
Orlando Sentinel also covered this story
but neither the Orlando weekly nor the
Sentinel told carried a picture of this
supposedly racist teacher that is
because the racist teacher and suppose
it white supremacists Sunday Brown is a
black woman what race was she supposedly
attacking jihad terror and Islamization
of course yet of course Aslam is not
really a race as any sane person knows
and Muslims are not of a single race but
of all races but the Orlando weekly an
Orlando Sentinel are out to destroy
Sunday Browns career and livelihood for
the crime of opposing jihad violence and
the spread of Sharia to non Muslim
countries they have targeted her because
she reportedly tweeted that Imams
worldwide instruct Muslims to invade
Western countries out read them
overthrow governments kill infidels and
implement Sharia law are there Imams and
other Muslim leaders who have preached
such things of course there are examples
are not hard to find and Brown has also
retweeted posts from identity Europa
which both a weekly and Sentinel call
identify Europa and which they claim is
white supremacist because the hard left
anti-defamation league says so now is
the ADL a reliable guide to such matters
that's highly questionable but not to
the weekly or the Sentinel in any case
even if identity Europa is white
supremacists to argue that Sunday Brown
is also white supremacists for
retweeting something they said or is
tainted by or responsible for all their
views because she retweeted one thing
they said well that's ridiculous by any
rational measure but with the Orlando
weekly in the Sentinel as with all the
establishment media
we've departed from rationality long ago
this witch hunt against Sunday Brown is
just one of many nowadays people who
express the slightest opposition to
Jihad terror or any hesitation about the
project of inundating Western countries
with Muslim migrants and are not just
hard as racist bigoted Islamophobes that
defamation has been going on for well
over a decade but now they're targeted
professionally the weekly and the
Sentinel ran these stories to try to get
Brown to lose her job
the leftist Islamic Alliance through its
tools in the establishment media wants
to drive all those who do not echo the
hard left agenda out of the public
sphere altogether they're applying
Hillary Clinton's call to use peer
pressure and shaming against those who
get out of line and are endeavouring
quite simply to destroy all dissent and
all dissenters I myself have been
subjected to this for years the cowardly
establishment right has long been
intimidated into avoiding me and all
others who speak about how jihadis used
the texts and teachings of Islam to
justify violence and a few years ago the
thuggish hate monger Nathan mean of
Georgetown University led a campaign to
get me cancelled from a speaking
engagement in California that actually
had nothing whatsoever to do with
Islamic Jihad he just wanted me and
others who speak the truth about the
jihad threat to be shunned and
ostracized everywhere in every context
in every connection this extends even to
basic efforts to make a living the
Washington Post a few years ago got
Terry Jones the famous Koran burning
pastor fired from driving for uber even
though that wasn't he wasn't burning
currents in his car as he carried
passengers around but it's clear that
they didn't want Jones to be able to
make any kind of living anywhere it's
also clear that if I quit this work
today and got a job selling real estate
or driving a truck the likes of Nathan
lien and the Washington Post and other
leftist totalitarians would publicize
the fact and get me fired and that's not
just me after all these years I'm used
to this and expected Sunday Brown
however is a different story she's not a
professional activist or writer she's a
schoolteacher a private citizen she and
others like her do not deserve this
public shaming and persecution simply
for opposing what everyone should oppose
Jihad mass murder and Sharia oppression
if Bridgewater middle school or Valencia
college where Sunday Brown works
fire her there should be protests every
lover of freedom in the Orlando area
should if Brown is fired picket the
school that fires her asking why they're
carrying water for murderers and
oppressors it's high time we pushed back
against this incipient totalitarianism
and put an end to this peer pressure and
shaming and destruction of people's
lives and careers because they said
something that the leftist establishment
doesn't like if we don't it's clear this
totalitarian straitjacket will you be
applied to us ever more tightly until it
won't be possible for anyone to be
employed anywhere unless they say and
think what Big Brother demands that they
say and think say no to this now say yes
to free thought on Robert Spencer
[Music]